do
and welcome to this meeting of the
council
i am councillor paul ekpanyong chairman
of mid suffolk district council and i
will be chairing the meeting today
before the meeting commences i would uh
like everyone to join me in a minute
silence to commemorate international
holocaust remembrance day which is today
and pay tribute to the memory of the
victims of the holocaust
thank you
[Applause]
may i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
the toilets are situated outside the
meeting room opposite the stairs
cold water is also available in the
breakout area outside the meeting room
if the fire alarm should sound please
leave the meeting room by the following
by following the fire exit signs and
meeting and meeting on the ipswich town
football club training pitch
do not re-enter the building until you
are told it is safe to do so
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to silent
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting you are also
consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
finally can i remind all councillors to
speak directly into their microphones
and refrain from covering the microphone
with their papers when speaking
so
with that i will move to the agenda
and just begin with can i ask all
counsellors to ensure that their
questions and debate are succinct
to the point and not a repeat of other
questions and comments that have
preceded them
um i'm going to be allowing um
approximately 45 minutes for each of the
motions that are tabled this evening so
hopefully that will be a sufficient time
if we
uh crack on through the agenda as i've
indicated
and i do want to obviously want to make
sure that we have a fair and reasonable
debate
uh it will also be my intention at the
approximately the two hour mark for us
to take a short break
so with that we move to the
first item on the agenda please
apologies for absence
thank you chair i have received
apologies for absence from councillors
field guthrie brewster and humphreys
thank you
are there any declarations of interest
by councillors
i see none
uh council mellon
thank you chair um
on page 31 it says that the business of
the meeting was concluded and my
understanding was that the meeting was
adjourned so i'm not sure if that is
correct thank you
so councilman melania mean foreign
should be adjourned so we will make that
correction
thank you
council of war boys
yesterday um on page
20 um described
25b
28
it says i gave examples of the
devastating effects of gambling i didn't
give specific examples
what i did say
was along the lines of that for many
people gambling was a relatively
harmless activity
but for some the effects of gambling
addiction were devastating
and the the rest it was therefore
important that the council
sent a strong message i think my exact
words were drew a line in the sand but
right could that be corrected sure thank
you
um are there any other issues with
accuracy
uh in which case could i have a proposal
for the minutes please
councillor
haddigan
thank you
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to con oh
we're not doing that are we okay for
sure
we're going to do this one by show of
hands i beg your pardon so all those in
favor please show
thank you very much that's carried
so that takes us then to item number
four this is paper
mc slash two one slash one eight
this is to confirm the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting held on the 18th
of october
2021 and again it's for accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
councilor mellon
thank you again sir um can i just query
the fact that it's listed as an
extraordinary meeting i understood this
was actually just a continuation of the
previous meeting thank you
um chair that that was called as an
extraordinary meeting to complete the
business so it was outside of an
ordinary council meeting so that we only
had those because it's classed as an
extraordinary meeting because those were
the only specific items we had on the
agenda for that meeting
so it was outside of the normal ordinary
meetings and we if it was a normal
council meeting we would have had other
items on the agenda for that
okay
you satisfied counselor mellon
yes thank you super
are there any other issues with accuracy
for those particular minutes
okay can i have a proposal please
counselor muller and could i have a
secondary council possible
and again can we do this by show of
hands all those in favor
that's that is carried thank you very
much indeed
so that takes us to item five this is
paper mc
oblique two one oblique one nine
chairman's announcements so uh you will
have that paper in front of you
um i guess the
from my point of view it was good to see
several of you at my civic service which
we held at the
salvation army and stone market um and
that particular event raised
over 300 pounds
for each and to date we've
actually achieved just over 1100 pounds
and counting so thank you all for your
support
item six is the leaders announcement so
i hand over to i would like to invite
councillor morley to present her update
councillors this item is not for debate
council warboys
sure
did you actually
receive a response to your letter
uh requesting that the message should be
excluded from the
the voter id measure
be excluded from the elections bill i
notice you wrote the letter and thank
you for that
how did you receive a response uh
council of war boys i regret to inform
you that the minister has yet to respond
i beg your pardon
there's been no response no yeah
okay
right so uh we're back to item number
six this is the leaders announcements i
would like to invite councillor morley
to present her update
uh councillors this item is not for
debate and any questions apart from
points of clarification should be
directed to councillor morley outside of
the meeting so councillor morley please
thank you chair
i realize we're fast approaching
february but i would like to start by
wishing you all a happy new year
i would also like to take this
opportunity to publicly thank councillor
wendy turner for all her service to the
residents of her ward and the council
as you all know wendy resigned over the
christmas i'm sorry councillor malik
councillor ebern
sorry chair but you did ask that people
don't speak with their things over the
mic and it's quite difficult to hear
because counselor morty's got a very
quiet voice so if you could move your
laptop to the side and speak a bit
nearer that'd be really helpful thank
you
i would like to take this opportunity to
publicly thank councillor wendy turner
for all her service to the residents of
her ward and the council
as you all know wendy resigned over the
christmas period as she has really
relocated elsewhere in the country to be
with her wider family
i'm sure you will all join me in
thanking wendy and wishing her the best
for the future
of course that does mean we have a
by-election on the 17th of february
and i am sure we will all see much more
of each other pounding the streets and
knocking on doors between now and then
it was only october but it feels like a
lot longer since we were last all
together like this in the council
chamber
of course that was before omicron took
hold and it is fantastic that we are now
able to begin to operate slightly more
normally again
personally however i would like to
encourage all of our residents to
continue to be mindful of covingt
i will for example still be washing my
hands regularly using hand sanitizer and
wearing my mask in crowded spaces
even though i'm not obliged to do so
we have fantastic communities and
community spirit in mid-suffolk so i'm
sure everyone will continue to look
after each other and keep one another
safe and of course doing so means we
will also be able to keep our services
going and enable the economy to bounce
back stronger
i know none of us want to become more
familiar with more of the greek alphabet
anytime
soon
whilst i'm talking about covid i would
also like to put on record my personal
thanks and that of all councillors for
all of the work of our own teams
and also the other parts of local
government health and all the volunteers
that mobilized to deliver so many
booster jabs
in such a short period of time
it has undoubtedly helped us come
through this wave of omicron more
quickly and with few people getting
seriously ill or dying
you are all incredible people
as always our continued thoughts and
prayers are with the families and
friends of those who have tragically
died from covid and also with those who
are living with long covered
please can i encourage all those who are
eligible whether for your first second
booster or even fourth jack to make sure
you get it as soon as you can
i would also like to encourage all
eligible businesses
to make sure they are accessing
accessing the financial support that is
enabled
that is available from us to help them
through omicron
since our last council meeting the
council has issued 31 press releases
which you will receive and are on our
website and we have published three
councillor updates and town and parish
briefings
so i'm not going to spend time repeating
all of that information but i do want to
celebrate a few of them
so in no particular order
gateway 14 has been officially
designated as part of freeport east and
we can look forward to the
infrastructure work starting on site
shortly
the new visitor center and cafe at
needham lake has had its topping out
ceremony
and we are looking forward to the duck
and teapot opening very soon
we are continuing to develop new
affordable housing
and so it was great to see eight more
new homes being finished and occupied we
need a market at our former hq
with all of those eight people being
able to move in before christmas and
have their first christmas in their new
home
we've made significant progress against
our climate
change and biodiversity ambitions
as councillors were hearing about at the
briefing last week
it was amazing to see our officers
pulling out all the stops to get the
wool pit gp car park built in record
time to support the covid vaccination
program
our new four-day curiosity festival was
launched in stone market during october
half time half term
with a series of different events for
nine to 19 year olds that offered
practical tips and guidance on different
career paths as well as hands-on
experience and workshops to provide a
taster of the media tech and creative
job opportunities available locally
and of course we have continued to help
our residents in a number of other ways
including a holiday and food funded
schemes for children through half term
and over christmas
and the launch of our new ipad lending
scheme with suffolk libraries as part of
our digital skills work
and finally i'm really proud that
cabinet was able to sign off the
additional 5.1 million pounds worth of
investment for a range of projects to
boost the district's recovery from the
impact of the kovid pandemic
councillors will recall that the ideas
for this were developed together through
the detailed councillor workshops in the
summer last year
and we are now looking forward to seeing
the impact of these investments for our
residents
during 2022 and 2023
and finally i want to mention the
queen's platinum jubilee
a huge number of events are planned
across the district and whole county
throughout the year
as part of the new festival of suffolk
and so i would encourage all councillors
and residents to look out for these and
more local events so that we can make
2022 a year-long celebration
thank you chair
thank
thank you councilman
councillor eben
um chair platinum raise a point of order
please to the monitoring officer um
because you stated that we couldn't ask
questions of of the leader which is a
change for we've always been able to ask
questions at this point in time
especially when we're
we have not prepared so personally you
know for that and secondly you say we
can email questions but we haven't had
responses to questions from the last
counsellor me council meeting so i would
like some kind of confidence um that we
will get questions answered if the
monitoring officer could respond i'd
appreciate it thank you chair
thank you councillor eben
monitoring officer
thank you chair um first i'd just like
to emphasize the principle that as chair
of this meeting you have discretion
about how to
manage questions and debate
but i believe the situation remains that
questions for clarity on the
announcements that have just been read
out are permitted uh it's just a
restriction on any outside questions
outside of the announcements which of
course should be directed to councillor
morley outside of the meeting thank you
thank you emily i i i guess really i
ought to
encourage the cabinet to make sure that
they do respond to questions please
come from molly
council reborn if you
think there's something we haven't
replied to just drop me a line and i'll
i'll check out for you
okay
thank you uh countless cars
uh thank you chair as a point of order
again um
the leader actually referred to the no
necessary to wear masks but the protocol
for this meeting does say
and if i've got it right it is
recommended that face masks are worn at
all times inside the building whilst you
are moving around and less exempt and
obviously if you're speaking to remove
your face mask i do wonder actually
whether members should actually consider
their position on that we are not out of
the pandemic yet in fact cases in
suffolk and indeed in mid-supper are
still slightly rising i wondered whether
the leader had got a response to that
counselor
sure there is a response to that the
guidance is that we don't have to wear
masks and i said that i will be wearing
a mask
that is what she said
right
in accordance with council procedures
thank you chair um be advised that we
have pollock received the following
validated petition 132 valid signatures
regarding planning application dc 21 06
treble 3 land off a14 elmswell this is a
planning petition and will be dealt with
through the normal process thankfully
thank you
i will move to item number eight
questions by the public in accordance
with council procedures non-received
chair thank you
so we'll move then to item number nine
which is questions by councillors in
accordance with council procedures
members i refer you to the questions in
the table papers i would like to invite
councillor otton to ask her question
my question is to counsel richardson
the decision of the chancellor to axe 20
pounds universal credit uplift on
october the 6th 2021
has left many people in mid-suffolk
struggling to meet the costs of rising
energy bills
and many low-income families will be hit
by the increase in national insurance
from april 2023
plus the rising cost of living
we recognise the extra money that the
chancellor has made available but that
still leaves many
seeking to advice
what is mit suffolk doing to help and
support those individuals and families
who are facing financial
difficulties
thank you i'd like to
invite councillor richardson to respond
thank you chair there are a number of
points um to mention in response to
council offense very important question
uh not least because it touches on
several uh cabinet portfolios
at a local level services consisting of
communities customer services housing
and well-being are currently working
together to develop a seamless system
that will enable us to better understand
trends across the district and provide
targeted support where it is needed most
the county council is also bringing
together a range of stakeholders from
across the districts to form a poverty
board this will help us to bring
resources
understand issues and implement joint
initiatives to manage the impact of the
emerging crisis
moreover mid-suffolk also provides
advice centres with a three-year core
grant provision to ensure there is
longevity in providing support to people
this complements current housing and
welfare support provision within the
council so we already we already have
established systems to provide support
and advice to our residents
but we have also been going further in
providing a range of initiatives and
schemes to tackle the crisis and support
local people
these range from
tenancy support management where our
approach is one of support and the
income officers look at each tenant
individually looking at the situation as
a whole rather than just as the rent
owed
that may involve sign posting to other
agencies that can assist such as
citizens advice or referring to our
in-house tenancy support officers who
can help with maximizing income
budgeting and negotiating with creditors
similarly as part of our shared revenues
partnership we make the best use of our
remaining discretionary housing payment
budget which supports customers whose
rent is restricted for a variety of
reasons
similarly our council tax reduction
scheme also offers uh up to a 25 to
sorry up to a 95 reduction in council
tax for working age residents uh what on
a 100 reduction for pension age
residents
similarly our housing our household
support grants where new tenants are
called by their rent officer within the
first two weeks of their tenancy helps
to identify issues and provides greater
support to tenants at an earlier stage
this is beneficial as it builds rapport
with the tenants who get to know who
they need to go to if they have
difficulties with their rent and also
means we can assist with other benefit
claims earlier or on help with referrals
for debt
alongside positive interventions locally
we also support
support people to cook healthier meals
the department for education have
committed to three years funding for the
holiday activity and food programme
which provides free activities and meals
during school holidays to young people
who are eligible for free school meals
and as councils you know we've extended
that into the half term as part of the
one million pound well-being part
staff at both baber mid-suffolk are
coordinating this program making sure
that it's available to those families
that need it most and the family park
cooking sessions are a great example of
where of this whereby families are
encouraged to cook inexpensive healthy
meals together and minimize food waste
in addition to the support we provide to
individuals themselves
mid suffix community grant schemes are
administered on our behalf and provide
funding uh to voluntary and local
community groups that support residents
often those with specific needs with
over half a million pounds spent in this
financial year already
so in summary to the to the council of
arts question i want to provide
assurance that the cost of living crisis
is absolutely on officers uh radar and
they are preparing uh for the
intersectional impact on individuals and
families facing financial hardship the
funding from the chancellor's council
often quite rightly says is welcomed but
the focus must be on supporting people
into well-paid work whilst providing a
safety net uh to prevent people from
falling into crisis
that's why working with a breadth of
organizations is absolutely crucial in
connecting a coherent local system that
works for people across our districts
and and finally uh chair as as the
leader has already indicated as this is
the first question in the first full
council of the new year i want to
reiterate uh take this opportunity to
reiterate our commitment to delivering
for our residents with our new
performance framework covering our six
strategic priorities supported by
enablers our key enablers like finance
investment and planning we are in a
strong position to respond to what will
be a difficult
few months for many we know that with
rising inflation with the aftermath of
kovid our residents will be faced with
numerous challenges but i passionately
believe that this is the year mid
suffolk can rise to meet those
challenges and support our residents and
our communities thank you chair
thank you councillor richardson
councillor otton
would you like to ask a supplementary
question
thank you chair
i'm sure your mum would be delighted
with that political statement uh
councillor richardson
um yes uh supplementary on that question
um
i have been aware and made aware of an
elderly couple
one has just finished chemotherapy
the gentleman is in his 90s
they had no way of knowing how to access
all of those things that you have just
mentioned other than ringing me up
i have been able in fact to
give them a form
for surviving winter i've been able to
give them
the telephone number for the cab so my
question is can you assure me that all
of those people that need that help will
know exactly where to get that help from
and will the council make a supreme
effort to publicize all of the help that
may be available thank you
thank you councillor richardson thank
you chair uh yes of course we need to do
absolutely everything we can to ensure
that the support available from the
district council um is well publicized
and is accessible for all people in our
communities
and if councillor otton is happy to give
myself or officers the details of this
individual case we'd be more than happy
to look into it the other thing i would
mention is that obviously if residents
do contact councillors they are more
than welcome to forward those that
information about specific cases to
myself or to our communities and
wellbeing team as far as i'm aware we've
not been notified about this case but
members can give officers that
information directly rather than waiting
until asking a formal question for
council
thank you
i would now like to ask
invite counselor melon to ask his
question
thank you chair um it's a question for
councillor whitehead
during last year's budget discussion the
council agreed to set aside four million
pounds
for specific project areas to be agreed
uh by all councillor workshops and and
subsequently as we know cabinet agreed
in november the allocation of 5.1
million to the identified priorities
um how much of this money will have been
spent by the end of this current
financial year thank you
thank you chairman
and thank you uh council mellon for your
question
i appreciate the time that's been taken
to get to a point where we are starting
to spend these large sums of money
but this is public money we wanted a
cross-party consultation we hoped for a
consensus and most most importantly we
wanted to establish a well thought
through coherent suite of plans
now i feel we are there it should be and
will be full steam ahead
as you know there is a comprehensive set
of initiatives that are supported by the
5.1 million
and will be delivered over varying time
periods
they were at different stages of
development when cabinet made its
decision back in november
and there are different delivery models
for achieving the outcomes that are
being put in place
as an example a number of them require
the recruitment of additional fixed term
staff which i'm pleased to say is
happening but it means that the level of
spending this year will be limited by
when the successful candidates can take
up their roles
because when one embarks on new projects
initiatives it is difficult to predict
precisely what rate they will spend
our managers have made an assessment of
what they think is likely to be spent by
the end of march
and based on what they currently know
this stands at somewhere between two and
fifty thousand and three hundred
thousand pounds
but i know this figure will be
considerably higher during next
financial year as the activity increases
when the allocation of the money was
approved the report outlined that
expenditure would be reported to cabinet
on a quarterly basis
as part of the general fund monitoring
report
that has we do with the growth
efficiency fund so this is where you
will be able to see the detail in the
future thank you thank you councillor
whitehead uh councillor mellon would you
like to ask a supplementary
yeah thank you chair um very grateful
for that response um but does he think
that uh the commitment
to spend the 5.1 million would be
enhanced if it came with a detailed
timetable for the spending thank you
[Music]
the cabinet paper which i think ran over
about six pages i think it had somewhere
between 49 and 51 bullet points
as i kept counting the change but 51
projects it's a great deal of detail i
mean some of those are four figure
amounts there's a six figure amounts
and you know each one of those has been
assigned to a assistant director a
corporate manager and i say as far as
i'm concerned as this agreement goes
through its full steam ahead and all of
those are seen as valued projects and
need to be delivered as soon as possible
thank you
i would now like to ask ours councillor
even to put her question
thank you very much chair i hope the
answer to my question will be a little
bit more succinct um
my question is since september 2020
individuals can claim 500 pounds from
the self-isolation support payment
scheme if they cannot work you to
self-isolation in covid
what percentage of claims received have
been paid and how much government
funding is the council still holding
thank you chair
thank you again chair and thank you
council event for your question as
simply as possible
as at the 23rd of january 2022
mitsubic had received 493 applications
of these
137 have been paid
296 have been refused and 60 are still
awaiting a decision
the percentage therefore they've been
paid from the 433 that have been
determined
is 32
in terms of the funding that we are
holding for the government
our initial allocation was 126.5 000
so with 137 payments made to date we
currently have 58 000 pounds remaining
thank you
thank you councilor whitehead uh
councillor eben would you like to ask a
supplementary
um thank you chair and i really
appreciate councillor whitehead's
success response thank you um
can i just ask um
what
you know that's that's quite a low
percentage 32 percent and i suspect that
um a lot of that is people you know four
forms and and unusual circumstances that
people you know aren't quite clear
perhaps about how they're um how they
need to claim it what they need to do
and so on so i just wondered what help
because obviously you know people who
are claiming this money are in desperate
need of the 500 pounds um due to their
circumstances and i just wonder what
help we are providing claimants to do
that thank you
thank you um
perhaps not quite succinctly but um this
these sort of funds are processed
through the shared revenues partnership
committee
sorry shared revenue's partnership and i
sit on the committee that monitors that
and i think
this may help i hope that
an extract from the minutes on the 8th
of september
and this is verbatim council white had
noted the self-isolation support scheme
seemed to receive a large proportion of
applicants
from people who were ineligible and
that's what was the reason for this the
shared revenue partnership operations
manager explained that people who had
heard of the scheme might make
speculative claims but reported the
application process guided those who
didn't qualify away from applying so
councillor white had asked for
reassurances that responses from claims
weren't being missed and their claims
refused the sharia news partnership
operations manager confirmed that
responses were not being missed and the
claimants were given additional time to
provide information and i know
i can assure her that the chevrolet
partnership staff are very diligent and
very caring people and you know really
do go the extra mile to to help these
clients
thank you
so we now move on to item
matherson yeah
yeah point of order chair the the um
we we are required to submit these
questions um three clear days in advance
which is to say last friday
and um it used to be the um the practice
that the the written answers
um were made available um a few minutes
before the start of the council meeting
and that seems to be no longer the case
along with the the leaders announcements
as well and it does seem to be part of
an incremental process of making life
more difficult to hold the
administration to account
i'm not sure what your point of order is
councillor
so to to be clear i i'm asking the
monitoring officer for for advice on
whether we should not be continuing to
receive those answers uh in advance of
the start of the meeting
if we've submitted them in advance by
that number of days
chairman i'm happy to answer that
question although not technically a
point of order because there isn't a
procedure rule that governs
uh the providing of responses to
questions from either councillors or the
public
the the cabinet member or the
chairperson or the leader who's uh
responding can choose the format in
which they wish to respond
and the critical part is that the uh
question and answer is produced in full
in the minutes so that's printed
verbatim in the minutes equally with the
leaders announcements it is at the
discretion of the leader as to when she
wants to publish
any announcements in advance or whether
she wishes to just give that on the
night in in the chamber there aren't any
procedurals that gav that govern that
aspect of the question and answer
process
thank you very much so we'll now move to
item 10 on the agenda this is paper mc
oblique 2-1 oblique 2-0
overview and scrutiny committee report i
would like to ask councillor welum to
introduce this paper which is for noting
only
my microphone is working
how this one is
right thank you
right yes so this report covers meetings
in october
november and december last year
and all of these three meetings were
joint meetings with weber members
i'd like to refer to the review of the
citizens advice it has been a difficult
two years for citizens advice
committee was played was pleased with
the reassurance that citizens advice
had coped well and adapted to changing
circumstances and extra workload through
the pandemic
funding continues to be an issue you
will see the recommendation to cabinet
that index linking be applied to their
three-year rolling program of funding
a meeting of
mid-suffolk over the unscrutiny took
place two weeks ago
we don't have the minutes and and i'll
just refer to a couple of points that
were raised then because they are
pertinent
we considered the general fund and the
hra budgets and four-year outlook also
we considered a call-in
of a cabinet decision in respect of the
district's taxi licensing policy
the committee resolved that the matter
be referred back to cabinet for
reconsideration
yeah my report is only for noting but
i'll be happy to try to answer any
queries on the report
thank you chair
thank you councillor willem are there
any questions for the councillor
councillor ebern
thank you very much chair thank you
councillor wellam for your report um
you've noted councillor wellam that um
the
overview and scrutiny committee
said that the um
housing and the work between the
citizens of ice bureau and housing could
be improved um i wonder if you could
elaborate on that what what exactly
needs to be improved thank you chair
uh yeah there are a couple of aspects
there but i think the most significant
is um councillor richardson
in one of his answers referred to the
joined up working between well among
housing officers
to help residents in rent arrears
the proposal by citizen's advice was for
council officers and shared revenue
partnership officers to work together to
take a single view of debt in other
words
uh rent and council tax
and councillor flatman assume assured
the committee that she would ensure that
was done
um the other aspect was that
there had been a suggestion from
citizens advice
that they should jointly with
mid-suffolk district council fund an
officer
to to help with the coordination um
there didn't seem to be
any um
plan for uh mid-suffolk to to help with
that
to jointly fund it so citizen's advice
have funded that post themselves
thank you councillor councilman
uh thank you chair um i'd just like to
ask uh councillor wellam uh with respect
to the um
resolution uh regarding um a uh scoping
of the provision of transport within the
district uh and i'd just like to know if
there was any time scale
on when this was likely to be taking
place thank
you council welum thank you councillor
mansell um
we we are about to start on that process
we haven't yet had we had a meeting to
scope
what we would be doing
um and we have
we're planning to meet with the
passenger transport
manager from suffolk county council um
who is
keen to work alongside us with us to
for the benefit of mid-southwest
residents obviously we won't be looking
at the whole of suffolk with him he will
be helping us as we're looking at
mid-suffolk and the what's available and
what needs to be available in
mid-suffolk
that first meeting with him is
is planned to be within the next
fortnight or so
thank you councillor willem that report
uh counselors was for noting only so we
will now move to item 11 on the agenda
which is in two parts so we'll deal with
item 11a first this is paper jac oblique
2 1 oblique 10. this is the half-year
report on treasury management in
2021-22
i would like to invite councillor muller
to introduce this item and to move the
recommendations in the report
it is a requirement of the code of
practice on treasury management that
council formally notes the half-year
position and that it was in accordance
with the approved strategy and
indicators
therefore although the recommendations
are for noting council will ask just for
noting council will still be required to
vote
so if i call on councillor muller please
thank you very much chair
this is the joint treasury management
report covering the position for the
first six months of the financial year
2122
it provides details of performance
effects of decisions taken during that
period and compliance with the council's
treasury management policy
the report explains the factors
affecting the strategy and activities
including the regulatory framework
economic conditions interest rate and
liquidity risk
interest rates during the year continued
at very low levels and the bank of
england base rate remained at 0.1 per
cent
the economic recovery from the
coronavirus pandemic continued to
dominate the first half of the financial
year
the easing of restrictions boosted
activity in the second quarter of the
calendar year
helping push gross domestic product up
by 5.5 percent quarter on quarter
the employment rate increased and
economic activity rates decreased
suggesting an improving labor market
picture
the annual cpi inflation rose to 3.2 in
august and the bank of england now
expects inflation to exceed 4
by the end of the calendar year owing
largely to developments in energy and
goods prices
more specifically for our council
banking activities undertaken were
within the daily bank account limits
the council reduced its debt by 9
million
all investment activities undertaken
were in accordance with the approved
counterparty list
the council's investment activities
including average returns can be found
at appendix c of the report
investment in funding circle has reduced
as unallocated funds have been reclaimed
and existing loans repaid
investment reduced by 31 000 leaving the
balance at 30th of september at 131 000.
the council is compliant with the upper
limits for interest rate exposure
and the investment activity undertaken
for the half year was done so in
priority order of security and liquidity
over yield as prescribed in the treasury
management strategy
there are two
recommendations on page 49 of our papers
3.1 and 3.3
and i would like to propose those and
could i ask for a second to please
thank you
thank you thank you mr chairman i'd like
to second those
i'll move to questions counselors may
ask as many questions as they wish
however
they must be relevant to the subject
under discussion and please can they be
succinct and to the point
counselor autumn
it's on now
um yes i'd like to ask question page 60
um where it states if i can find it on
here
um about the government's
greening finance
road map to sustainable investing
you've said here that you will be
looking at that
and i would really like a commitment
that we get some feedback from that
i believe that companies particularly
aviva have stated that they will no
longer invest in any company or
organization that does not have
my question is will you be taking this
seriously and will we be getting a
feedback about what exactly you are
doing in response to this
government finance roadmap to
sustainable investment
thank you chair yes thank you for your
question counselor yes we would take
this seriously thank you thank you
councillor mellon
yeah thank you chair um on page 52 of
the report at um paragraph 11.1
uh this is the section on environmental
implications
um it says that all council activities
will need to be reviewed as part of the
climate change task group
and i note that this wording is exactly
the same for the last two reports um it
does seem to indicate that there's an
ongoing process of environmental review
but i'm aware that the the climate
change task group has not met um
and i believe the work is seem to have
been closed so can we have some
clarification on that on that paragraph
please
uh thank you chip um thank you for your
question counselor i'm actually not
actually a member of that particular
group and i would ask perhaps whether um
the section one five officer or the
acting corporate manager red cage would
be able to answer that question please
thank you chad
thank you jeff thank you councillor
muller um just looking at the report i
think uh councillor mellon is right i
think cousin could you take them off
sorry
sorry looking at the report i think
councillor mellon is right i think that
paragraph has probably been in there for
a previous report and we do need to
update it so we will do that for the
next treasury management report thank
you
thank you catherine uh councillor ebern
sorry chair i was jumping the gun for
debate oh i can hold back
thank you
if there are no other questions then we
will move to debate
so countless will be allowed to speak
for three minutes and this will be timed
so who would like to go first
councillor ebon
sorry chair i i just felt that um
it's a very difficult time
for during covid times and so on and i
just felt that we should be thanking the
finance team particularly and obviously
the chair of the committee for the work
um
you know particularly the finance team
and their advisors of the work that
they're they're doing here um because
obviously it is you know complex and
ever-changing so i just wanted to make
sure that we did have a
vote of thanks for somewhere along the
lines and um i would also hope to um
that i i heard that
the officer stated that we were going to
change the paragraph about the climate
change task force and i just hope that
this treasury management is being
reviewed in some way um with regards to
the climate change
emergency that we
all voted on thank you
thank you councillor eber and i'm sure
with regard to the first part of your
commentary that we would all fully
endorse that and
i'm sure we can show our appreciation in
the normal manner for the work that the
finance team have been doing
yeah okay
thank you
uh does it
does anybody else wish to speak on this
counselor geek
thank you chair um
i'm sorry i think this might be a
question am i allowed to pose it i won't
expect an answer but i'm allowed to post
come back to your suggestion councillor
geek as we've passed the question can
you send your questions i'll give my
opinion in that case um
the the risk register at 8.2 says that
the likelihood of poor return on
investments is probable
um
i feel that uh if we're probably going
to get a poor return on investment
perhaps the investment shouldn't have
been made or should be rethought that
that is my contribution to the debate
and no doubt somebody will be able to
contract me thank you
thank you councillor geek
councillor passmore
thank you very much chairman i just
wanted to say i i do support the
recommendation um
this is perhaps a somewhat boring
subject to look at
but what we do need to remember and some
of us can go back many years like mrs
alton and one or two others of us and in
fact you've been on this council even
longer than i have um
but you know what we have to do is
safeguard public money
the point of that risk that i think has
just been made is important but we
always need to balance the issue of risk
and the reliability of returns some will
remember
the royal rather wild
expectations going back
many years of high risk investment
investments in ice and so on so i do
think the treasury team has got this
absolutely right i shall support the
recommendation um and we've got to be
very careful not to take undue risk with
this sort of system with what is public
money the returns are not very good at
the moment as we all know
um but nevertheless some return is a lot
better than none and trying to safeguard
what we've got albeit of course the
value of it sometimes is being eroded by
inflation but i should be very happy to
support the recommendation thank you
chairman
thank you thank you councillor parker
councillor whitehead
thank you chair
it strikes me looking at this risk
description that if the council achieves
a better return on investments than
planned there will be better more
resources available to deliver services
and i suspect the likelihood is probable
and the impact would be noticeable so
basically
the
you can't crystal ball where these
returns will be um they can be better or
they could be worse so i think just to
cancel the geek's point um whether it's
better or worse they is still probable
and noticeable thank you
thank you counselor
okay there are no further contributions
then i would like to ask uh councillor
miller if he wishes to add anything
thank you very much chair yes i'd like
to take um councillor eboy's point i
would like to pass on my sincere thanks
to catherine rebecca and the rest of the
finance team for the incredibly hard
work they've done through this very
difficult period thank you chair
thank you councillor muller
so i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair councillors could you
please open the vote in the modern.gov
app by clicking the plus sign in the top
right hand of the agenda screen as
selecting attendance and voting for
clarity we are voting on 3.1 and 3.3 as
recommendation 3.2 refers to baber that
vote is now open thank you
councillor welum can i take your vote
please
and counselor stringer
oh you're signed in now sorry thank you
thank you very much so that is carried
we will now move on to item 11b this is
paper mc oblique 2-1 oblique 2-1
gambling act 2005 statement of
principles three yearly adoption
i would like to invite council muller to
introduce this paper and to move the
recommendation in the report
thank you very much chair
councillor guthrie apologizes for being
unable to attend tonight unfortunately i
myself was unable to attend that
particular meeting through ill health
but councillor guthrie has sent me a
report which i'll read out to you now
the purpose of this report is to ask
council to adopt the amended statement
of principles as recommended by
mid-suffolk licensing and regulatory
committee on the 3rd of december 2021
it is a statutory requirement to review
and re-adopt the council's gambling
policy every three years
the decision to adopt the statement of
principles may only be taken by council
and cannot be delegated to the licensing
and regulatory committee
a reconsultation exercise to include the
no casino resolution was undertaken for
a 28-day period and no responses were
received
all changes to the policy are contained
within appendix b
the majority of amendments were purely
administrative with few changes that
were as a result of the amendments to
the gambling commissioner's guidance
the recommendation is that the draft
revision gambling act 2005 statement of
principles document as attached as
appendix a to this report be adopted for
publication and to take effect for three
years unless sooner revised from the
31st of january 2022
and i would like to thank the licensing
team for all their hard work during the
reconsultation process this exercise
thank you
thank you as a proposal please i propose
to have a second to please
uh do we have a second day for
council casting
sorry
oh councillor geek okay thank you
thank you chair i'd like to second uh
councillor i was at the meeting uh on
the 3rd of december and i must say i'd
like to echo his thanks to the licensing
officers who who've done a tremendous
job not not just the standard you know
perfect work that they make it's so
clear and so easy for us all to
understand what's going on
i can thoroughly recommend this to uh to
all members
thank you councillor geek
we will now move to questions uh usual
process applies so
does anyone have a question
with regard to this report
no
okay
we'll move on to debate
does anyone wish to uh begin counselor
brain dead
sorry counselor
i'm just
i was obviously disappointed that this
has to come back to us and for the
reasons that um i think are documented
in our minutes however i would just like
to add my sincere thanks to the team for
the amount of work they've put in and
i agree with councillor geek this is an
excellent document and will stand us
well for the next three years so thank
you so much
thank you councillor fleming apologies
for the brain hemorrhage there there
anyone else would like to say anything
okay in which case uh councilman muller
do you wish to add anything further
uh thank you chad i'd just like to say
uh thank you to councillor geek who was
president that meeting for her comments
uh reflecting the thanks for the team
that she did all the work thank you very
much thank you
okay thank you very much uh so i would
now like to ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote please
thank you chair that vote is now open in
the modern.gov app please can you place
your vote thank you
cancer well can i take your vote please
thank you
thank you
all right that is unanimously and so
that is carried so thank you all we will
move to item number 12.
this is paper mc oblique 2-1 oblique 2-2
this is the development of housing
revenue account business plans
i would like to invite councillor
hadingham to introduce this paper and to
move the recommendations in the report
councillor herdingham thank you chairman
good evening members
this evening i'm pleased to introduce to
introduce the report m c
21-22 the development of housing revenue
account business plans
the housing revenue account hra is the
financial account used to manage our
landlord activities
it is ring fenced in the law and can
only be used for providing services to
council housing tenants through the
collection of rents and charges
other council services are funded
through council tax and central
government support which benefit all
citizens of baby mid-suffolk regardless
of tenure
the hra business plan which is in
development will set out our income and
expenditure plans for delivering council
housing services as well as setting out
our key council housing priorities for
the forthcoming years demonstrating how
we intend to develop our services to
meet tenants expectations
this is timely work as we look to the
introduction of the social housing white
paper which sets out the actions the
government will take to ensure that
residents in social housings are safe
and are listened to live in good quality
homes and have access to redress when
things go wrong
the building safety bill which is the
next step in groundbreaking reforms to
give residents and homeowners more
rights powers and protections making
homes across the country safer
this will overhaul regulations creating
lasting generational change setting out
a clear pathway on how residential
buildings should be constructed
maintained and made safe
this alongside the introduction of our
council outcomes framework and the
development of our new build design
guide and technical specific
specification as well as a midpoint
review of our homes and housing strategy
an associated acting action plan
during the past few months we have been
listening to our stakeholders to develop
our approach to the plan
members will recall being invited to
respond to a survey and we've also used
last year's members workshops and the
work which centered on it on
on a stock take to contribute to the
priorities we have established this
report sets out the approach that has
been taken and identifies the areas of
focus most important to everyone and
will be incorporated into the plans
over the next couple of months will be
finite by
finalizing the plan with the intention
of the final version of the hra plan
being presented to full council for
comment shortly
moving forward each year the hra
business plan will be reviewed and
updated updated to set budgets and
charges for the year ahead whilst
providing an updated five-year plan for
our capital investment program
i would like to propose
recommendations set out in this report
and ask for a second thank you
thank you chair as ex
portfolio
for housing i'm very pleased to support
this
paper thank you thank you councillor
we will now move to questions and
counselors may ask as many questions as
they wish
and again please be succinct to make
sure they're relevant to the subject
under discussion and they must be a
question and to the point
who would counselor pass more
thank you very much chairman uh could i
just ask lavina you mentioned there that
the um
plan will be brought up shortly i just
wanted to ask give you any idea of a
time scale the reason i ask is because i
think it's really really important it's
done well there's a lot in it it's a
really important service that we provide
and my personal view would be waiting an
extra month a few weeks
would be beneficial to make sure we get
it absolutely right before it comes back
to the council to discuss it thank you
thank you uh
please
thank you very much chair and thank you
for the report counselor having them i
think it will be a good very good um
process to go through um one thing i
want to ask is whether sort of combining
paragraphs 4 29 430 which is about
improving neighborhoods um
could we
will that include and or if not could we
look at we'd talk about bits of open
space in neighborhoods that often get
used for parking you know they're either
extended bits of verges and then people
use them to park on and could we kind of
do some kind of program to either
help people to if they've got parking
issues somewhere else for them to be
parking or actually using those pieces
of land to to plant trees or or
something else on to prevent parking i
mean i've got several spots in my ward
i'm sure everybody can recognize this as
a as an issue but it's how we it's kind
of two issues together the parking and
the use of the green spaces so will this
um program be be looking at that um and
make sure that's incorporated thank you
thank you chair
thank you counselor thank you
um yes yes i'm sure you can look into
that can't we gavin
thank you
uh councilman
yeah thank you chair um it's just a
quick point of clarification on the top
of page 148 paragraph 9.5
it talks about building more homes and
encouraging
under-occupiers it seems to me there's
probably a phrase missing there i'm all
for encouraging people but i'm not quite
sure what we're encouraging them to do
there thank you
councillor harrington
oh sorry thank you um i think it means
um
under occupiers it should probably have
a um a hyphen
i think that's what we're saying it's
just under occupiers who are not you
know fully using the or the bedroom sort
of thing
is that right gavin sorry
sorry yeah um
the the reference is obviously building
buying more houses
increases our supply obviously meets the
needs of those that are are in need of
accommodation i think the important
point to note from from that comment and
apologies if it's it's not clear um
we've got a finite amount of of housing
and part of the plan will be to make
best use of what we've got that's not to
that would be through encouragement and
through support for individuals that may
not want to downsize now but may want to
downsize in the future to maximise the
existing stock we have
okay
councillor autumn
uh yes i'm interesting to read the
statement at 4.35
involving tenants in running the service
and the development of an innovative
governance model
i'd like to know whether the tenants on
that
model whichever way
it's developed will they actually have
proper voting rights in order that they
feel that their time is spent
um
constructively and are not just there um
as someone you know to to just nod and
be um
feel to be involved in the running of
the service i really think it's
important if you're going to do this
that they really feel that their time is
spent
properly thank you
councillor
thank you and um thank you for your
question and i'm sure we will take it on
like you said we want our residents to
feel they're being listened to our
tenants to feel they're being listened
to and that their points are valid and
we will certainly take that on board
thank you very much
council of war boys
thank you
sorry i just untangled myself a little
bit
thank you chair
um
pack of night digital transformation uh
just a question about this
more and more of the council's
businesses
run online for efficiency purposes
at present it's reported there's 28 of
tenants that signed up to the my home
portal um
the reason i'm raising this is 46
percent of staff said they actively
promote
digital channels to tenants
um
shouldn't more staff be actively
promoting this service to tenants so
that all tenants are aware of the
that this is the means in which they can
contact the council
about the property the tenancy
thank you
thank you i was just you were looking at
gavin or yes i beg your pardon i should
i'm sorry i just don't give you the
chance to respond um
you know
i would say yes you're right but i'll
ask i'm gavin if he was or his opinion
thank you
thank you for the the question um these
are obviously survey results that
they're obviously uh taken in the
context of the the number of staff that
that responded
and obviously depending on roles and
responsibilities you might naturally
assume that housing offers spending
quality time with a tenant might talk
about how they manage their home and
their tenancy perhaps slightly
differently to a a plumber that's there
to to to fix
a leak
clearly we want to promote the benefits
of digital use of of the tools that are
available
if that provides efficiencies and
improves the service that that tenants
receive directly so
yes we will be looking to to ensure that
staff promote not only digital
transformation and digital
transformation of the landlord service
but promote all the opportunities
promote the opportunities to be part of
the land or service having a say
in in say where it's just been discussed
chair yeah if we could return to the
under occupancy um problem um
the
the people who are most likely to be to
be in in that situation are under
occupying and i'd be interested if if um
officers have got any information about
the extent of the problem within the
house housing service but the
my question really is are we putting
enough resources into
helping people to move because those
people are the least likely to have the
capacity to to organize their own
moving and and when you think about it
the cost of providing an extra couple of
bedrooms
additional bedrooms somewhere is huge
and the cost of actually
releasing a couple of bedrooms in an
unoccupied house
is
far less even if we put much more effort
into it so can we can we focus more
effort than we are already are on that
and if it works well i just wonder
whether we should extend
the service that we provide to the
private sector where there's lots more
people under occupying who again are the
ones that are least likely to have the
ability to to deal with it themselves
thank you
thank you um
well yes i'll say well certainly put
some more effort into it but if you if
you would like an answer from gavin then
i will welcome
thank you um
i can't give you any any statistics
tonight in relation to tennessee audits
or the level of under occupancy partly
because it's not been a necessarily a
direct focus of the landlord service in
recent times hence why developing the
hra business plan we see it as an
opportunity
i can tell you from experience that um
in the past working for baby mid suffolk
we have promoted the benefits of
downsizing because clearly if you're
under occupying you're paying larger
utility bills uh et cetera et cetera and
i can tell you about some lift
experience in terms of a tenant that
contacted me personally eight years
later because she'd kept the letter on
the mantelpiece until the point that she
felt comfortable to move
and i think that just demonstrates the
approach that we need to take this in
terms of developing an approach to under
occupancy whether that be around
incentivizing that incentives could be
from carpets and decoration of the new
home to
that level of handholding that you
describe through the process because for
anyone moving is clearly can be a
traumatic and a big deal so
we need to focus on that focus on what
tenants need
and would desire to benefit them to
benefit to move and and thus benefit us
in terms of bringing those properties
back into to stop so that will be the
approach taken
thank you thank you gavin councillor
masterson do you have another question
um
council carter
earth thank you um but just just say a
point to councils including the council
of madison
um
i pre i didn't declare myself as a
council attendant previously
but i am one who canceled the council
attendant um
but we can't say that uh these people
are the least
be at least able to do it we are making
methods to actually allow for
um
to make it easier to
swap homes we have the provisions there
we are making the movements in the right
direction i'm sorry counselor what is
your question
my question
points to
statements regarding that these people
were least likely to
our attracts might matter
i suspect you don't have a question
today i'm afraid so we'll move on
councillor
thank you chair um yeah my question is
about the digital transformation
um i have an uncle who's 94
and there's no way i'm ever going to
persuade him to get an ipad or even to
have wi-fi put on to his council
bungalow and he often asks me
to
to do things on his behalf well because
i have to sign in and swear that i'm
mr finbo or whoever
so
what i wondered well the question is
this
is it possible that one of the tenants
who doesn't want to get involved in the
digital transformation
can appoint somebody to to act on their
behalf
in signing up to my home and so on
that's a very good question and i think
as a beautiful son i think we've all
frankly been there with our parents but
um i will um i'll pass it on to gavin
his experience
thank you for the question um it's one
that we deal with with now whether it be
digital correspondence or or perhaps
written so there is the facility and the
ability to support a tenant to have um
an advocate acting on their behalf um
and certainly with regards to the my
home portal for which we've now got
nearly 4 000 tenants signed up to that
so
that gives them the ability to monitor
their rent account
receive an electronic newsletter from us
on a monthly basis there would be that
ability to do that providing the
necessary checks and balances have been
carried out to protect the tenants and
attendance information
uh any other questions
okay well in which case then um
we shall move to debate and uh
councillors have three minutes each to
make their points um
did they want to kick off the debate
councilmember
i didn't really want to speak first but
they go um no one else seemed to put
their hand up um
i will be supporting uh this motion i i
think it's uh it is a timely
motion that we need to review our our
business plan for the housing revenue
account uh and i i think that an awful
lot her of work has gone into it already
that it's great that we've got um
involvement from the tenants themselves
and we've done some extensive
consultation um and i think an awful lot
of interesting points have been raised
um in the questions that other members
have
have posed this evening
and i trust that um these will be taken
on board uh when it comes to the final
business plan
um and on the subject of under occupancy
which has been raised by a couple of my
colleagues i think there are some a
couple of missing words in that
statement uh and i think that a lot of
the uh
the issues that um have been brought to
my attention regarding under occupancy
is to do with the lack of smaller
properties in the right places that a
lot of people have been living um in
their home their large family home for a
long time and yes they want to downsize
but they want to stay in the same place
they want to stay in that village or
town that you know people in my ward
don't want to be offered a two-bed place
in or small places stow market
so i i really hope that that is taken on
board i i think those um actual issues
were listed in priority and it was
reasonably high up in the in the ranking
so i really do hope that we can do more
to to help uh ease that situation uh so
i think that uh
in summary i think this is a a welcome
uh move uh and i really do look forward
to
seeing the business plan into course uh
hopefully before april so we've all got
time to read it and digest it uh and i'm
looking forward to the debate and the
discussion and the questions once we
actually have the business plan in front
of us but i will be supporting this
motion which is to go ahead with the
review of the hra business plan thank
you
thank you councillor mansell i guess you
mean the recommendations um
does anyone else wish to speak
okay if not then um i'd like to ask um
well i would like to ask the corporate
manager for
sorry the corporate manager governance
and civic office to conduct the
electronic vote please
thank you chair that vote is now
openingmodern.gov please place your vote
thank you
councillor willem can i take your vote
voted thank you
right members that's a unanimous vote in
favor so that's carried
so we will now move on to item 13. this
is paper mc
oblique21 oblique23 this is the draft
committee timetable for
2022-2023
i call on uh councillor molly
thank you chair
we published the
draft committee timetable and i'd like
to ask you all to approve it there is a
an update in the table of papers
with one
minor change that actually relates only
to baber and not to mid suffolk
thank you
right thank you councillor molly right
but
we should now move on then uh to item
number 14.
sorry about that do we have a second for
that please
counter melon
um
mr chairman i'd like to propose an
amendment actually to the
is that is that appropriate at this
moment it needs to be seconded first it
has to be seconded first i think i
believe we have to second first then we
can go on to the council of richardson
happy to second that chair thank you
councillor
right so now we've got that proposed and
seconded
uh
we can go to
council members
thank mr chairman um
just reviewing the timetable um
uh i note that uh baber district council
has
12 meetings
scheduled for the next
council year
while we have seven and i'd like to
propose that we have
that we add in two reserve dates in june
and october
for extra meetings not currently on the
schedule
so that we ensure that we cover
the council's business in a timely
fashion thank you
do you have a second for that councilman
um
chair i'd be very happy to second that
um we've obviously had issues over the
last year with meetings being cancelled
through no fault of anybody's in terms
of covid and so forth and then
struggling to fit in um other meetings
we've also had a meeting that has um
extended a very long time and we didn't
have a then we weren't able to adjourn
that to another meeting because we
didn't have the space so i think it
would just be common sense
really to put in two provisional
meetings in june and october um no we
haven't said august or christmas um
because we don't think that would be
particularly popular but if we could
have just provisional meetings so we've
got them all in our diaries for june and
october and then that would help um in
terms of any changes to the current
timetable thank you chair
thank you councillor eben i'll ask the
leader of the council councillor molly
to
let us know if she accepts that or not
it's a tricky one because i don't really
want to
put dates in the diary
when we don't actually have council
business to conduct i don't feel
strongly
enough to oppose it to be quite honest
but i'm not keen on spending council
money if there is no business
to be discussed
so um
i would like to know what other people
think actually
councillor welland
i think it's a i think it's very good
idea that we have these dates in the
diary it's it's much better to have the
dates in the diary and find that we've
got too many meetings and it is to find
that we've got
we've got too much business and we just
don't know how we're going to put them
in so we've got the dates in the diary
and
one of the other recommendations is a
way of not holding meetings if there's
no no business
so why don't we just put the dates in
the diary and then they're there
and we can keep we can keep those dates
free and it will mean that the chamber
is booked and i think that is important
to have to to have the chamber reserved
on those particular dates
so that if we do need a meeting it's
there we don't need a meeting we just
don't have a meeting
counselor hicks
thank you mr truman i think the problem
we've got here is what we're being asked
to decide today is the dates in the
diary that is before us so we can only
agree to accept this but if there's a
provision to come back with other
meeting dates they would have to come
back at a separate meeting with those
exact dates for us then to vote to put
into the calendar so we can't really
decide that today anyway all we can
decide is the dates that's on the paper
before us
but
that's for another day i would suggest
that what's being proposed is to be
sorted out for another day
counselor pass more yeah very quickly
thank you chairman all i was going to
say was by all means if we have a date
provision he provided there was really
something to do i don't think for a
moment anybody's suggesting having
meetings for the sake of it clearly not
that would be futile um
but i do think we need to have that
coordinated agree with matthew's point
that it needs to be looked at carefully
so i'm not against it don't take that
the wrong way please but let's just
think of it
specifically what how would it work and
make sure and i would make a suggestion
again for the others to decide it should
be at the chairman's discretion or some
mechanism so that we do
there is a way of making sure that is
legitimate sensible business to do and i
know nobody's suggesting otherwise but
we just need to make sure it's done in
the right way rather than decide it here
and now a date or anything like that
thank you chairman
thank you come from passmore
so i guess we moved to on this
particular right we need to go back to
the proposal and secondary of the
original motion to see if they accept
them and yeah so councillor morley
i think it's over to you to decide
whether you accept the amendment or not
um i think no i don't
um i'd rather we approved this as it is
but i will take away those two other
dates
and check because we don't know whether
the council chamber is available on
those dates
so i will take those two june and
october dates away and we'll check and
we will come back
if we can fit them in
council mellon do you wish to withdraw
your amendment for the time being or not
yeah no um i think we
do we move to debate on that issue
um i have a few words to say
thank you
um
i just do ask members to bear in mind
the situation we faced during this past
year where
we ended up
on multiple occasions having to have a
vote on the guillotine motion and extend
meetings
it seems reasonable to me if baber are
doing this
putting provisional
meetings in the agenda in into the the
timetable
uh and i haven't proposed specific dates
but i have proposed
a kind of a month
in which those meetings could take place
i i feel certain that the
the uh the chamber will be available on
on some days during those months
um
i think it would be sensible to have
space in the democratic program to
debate
um and also just remind uh members that
this um
this forum is not just for the
administration it is for all councillors
and um
the sort of definition of whether
there's enough business it's not just
about the administration's business it's
about whether councillors have questions
for the administration or or whether the
opposition has uh motions they want to
put forward
as well those are also part of the
business of the council
and so i would i would ask
members to support
my amendment to add a couple of extra
dates with the flexibility
that they could be fitted in at an
appropriate time
and i think that is a sensible way
forward thank
you thank you councillor does anyone
else wish to speak
yes thank you i mean i i have a lot of
sympathy with actually the suggestion
for more meeting dates um because
sometimes it's good fun to have a go at
each other across the chamber
and um
you know i
i i wouldn't want to miss that
opportunity but
i'm not sure that um the way i haven't
seen
um a written
um proposal here and i would like it to
be up to the chairman to decide whether
sensible business
is on the agenda and should be conducted
if it is then by all means let's have
those two dates
but it should be the chairman's
discretion
thank you council councillor richardson
thank you uh chair i think i'd like to
echo what council fleming and and
council morley have said i mean i'm
personally i i wouldn't object um to the
kind of the the key motivation behind
this which is to ensure we have those
reserve dates in mind i think obviously
it's worth reflecting on the fact that
we
we hope that the events of the last year
won't be repeated and so we won't be in
some of those unique circumstances again
um but i do think there's probably a
little bit more work to do in terms of
going away ensuring that dates are
mutually convenient for the officers
involved making sure making sure we've
got substantive business to take to
those council meetings and i do think
this is a bit of a rhetorical question
because i'm assuming the answer is no
that obviously these papers have been
published for about a week there would
have been opportunities i'm sure for
people to have got together to have
suggested changes i'm i'm assuming the
leader wasn't aware of this amendment
until just now there would have been
opportunities she's not she's shaking
her head starts to know there would have
been opportunities to come together give
us advanced notice that this amendment
was going to come forward and then reach
a mutually beneficial agreement i think
what we've said thus far is we're open
to the idea but we need a little bit
more information first so i think it's a
shame we couldn't have done this before
this meeting but it is what it is and
i'm sure we can we can revisit the
situation as and when we feel necessary
to call additional meetings that's
that's my view
thank you councillor richardson
councillor manson
uh thank you chair oh sorry
sorry did you say mansella motherson
manson thank you sorry um
thank you chair uh i i am i really don't
quite know um
what councillor fleming and councillor
richardson uh have got to object to this
because in essence they seem to actually
be agreeing with the fact that it would
be good to have some provisional dates
uh for extra meetings um and i'd just
like to come back on council fleming
we're not having a go at anybody but i
just think it's actually i get your
point it's great that we can actually
get together and discuss things we're
not having to go at one another
it actually makes me feel like i'm part
of a counselor when i come to a council
meeting when i'm sat at home in front of
a team's meeting i do not really feel
part of that community so i think it is
it's good for us to get together as a
group of councillors we should all be
working to the same ames um so we are
here together in the chamber to make
decisions about our communities and i
think there is absolutely no harm in
having this motion it is flexible enough
it just says within the months of june
and october we're not asking you to
pinpoint exact dates when you might or
might not be available when the chamber
is not available um
we all
know over the past few months we have
been sat in this chamber and i've almost
missed the last train home i do not like
to be here until quarter past 10 um
means i don't get home till night on 11
o'clock uh we all have to go without a
meal for the evening we don't want long
long meetings uh we don't want to have
our emotions put aside because they tend
to be at the end of the agenda they get
put aside and we have to have an
adjournment an extraordinary meeting and
that that was really difficult to put
into the timetable so there is
absolutely no harm in putting these
dates in the calendar as flexible dates
it gives us the flexibility and we are
not saying there has to be a meeting in
june and october it will of course be at
the chairs discretion as to whether
there is enough business to conduct
it just gives us that little bit of
flexibility what is the harm in it so
come on let's all vote for it it's not a
made big deal thank you
thank you councillor mansell councillor
matheson
yes
thank you chair yeah i merely wanted to
ask the monitor monitoring officer to
confirm that the chair actually has the
discretion already to cancel the meeting
if it's not needed
thank you chair um it's actually the
chief executive who has the authority to
convene meetings as the proper officer
for the purpose of issuing summons to
the meeting so it's actually the chief
executive's decision whether or not to
hold a meeting but of course he would
have a discussion with the chairman
about the business
that is
to be conducted or indeed the absence of
business to be conducted which would
result in a decision to cancel a
scheduled meeting
thank you
councillor geek
thank you chair just to um just to to
come uh add a little to councillor
matheson's uh topic there um over the
last uh three years we have experienced
in this council an awful lot of the
chairs casting vote where
where votes have been tied
half of this council
is the administration's party half of
the council is other parties
if
i i don't want anybody to think that
we're moving to a system where the chair
is the person who decides because that
has not been shown in the past to be
politically neutral shall i put it no
stronger than that
it is really essential that the business
of the council is the business of the
whole council it's not just the business
of the administration
thank you chad just uh didn't want to
make a meal of this and in the uh
pursuit of brevity i just wanted to
check that if we were to vote against
this motion
under the six-month rule would that
preclude us having council meetings then
in june and october
emily
is that i don't know that's the case
uh so the six-month role counselors
would
prevent you having another debate and
discussion on having meetings in june
and october so you wouldn't be able to
bring back another motion to request
those unless of course you had a third
of the council who wanted to revisit
that uh discussion within a period of
six months
um that being said you always have the
opportunity to request an extraordinary
meeting
under different provisions in the
constitution and so therefore it would
still be possible to convene a june or
october meeting
in another way thank you
thank you chair um
as someone who's proud of my hundred
percent attendance representing the
residents of clayton barham here in full
council and as someone who was planned
to have a holiday in june there's
someone who has to negotiate with his
spouse before that holiday can be
arranged to me the soon and it's when i
see this calendar and i put it straight
to my diary and then i tell my wife we
may be able to go on holiday may not
because i want to be here so as soon as
those dates if there are dates in june
october we put in the direct from my
point of view i'd be happy to see them
there as
provisional dates and get a member diary
and so i support that thank you
of war boys
i do apologize to advance for prolonging
this discussion but i'd like to ask
everybody to vote in favor of
adopting
the proposed two meetings
today
rather than put it off to a further
meeting and prolonging the debate even
further
thank you
you know i'm just a bit i i don't think
we're
we're all kind of saying the same thing
but if you were really serious about
this your leader would have approached
our leader two weeks ago and said we've
got this great idea let's come to a
conclusion let's reach a decision
unfortunately you haven't and you're j i
think you're just playing trying to play
games on this
uh it's really disappointing that you
can't actually do things and cooperate
with the administration rather than just
trying to hijack a meeting at the last
minute it's clearly just for a cheap
game honestly
[Music]
a good idea is a good idea whenever it
comes right
um
on the amendment
right councillors uh we're now going to
go to a vote on the amendment so um
we're getting all organized for that
bear with us
chair thank you that amendment is now um
in blue if you can vote on the amendment
proposed by councillor mellon thank you
councillor willem can i take your vote
for the amendment thank you
councillor flatman are you okay to vote
or are you having problems
not yet
just let me refresh
for a moment
no it's not coming through so can i take
it manually
oh has it it has yes sorry
okay
so chair that is 19 for the amendment
and nine against
so members that is carried so that
becomes the substantive motion
okay so now we have to go to a vote on
the substantive motion
and
chair just
just two seconds it's now coming live
chair that is now amended
so if you'd like to place your votes
that is now showing in blue thank you
standing up and putting my microphone on
i'm very sorry that was a bit of a
surprise because i've uh the
2.2 we're also voting on is that correct
that says that the chief executive
takes the decision as to whether there
is
enough uh
enough business to have a meeting now
should that not say that the chief
executive takes that decision in in
consultation with the uh with the uh
with both sides of the council
um
i'm surprised that we we haven't been
able to discuss that thank you
yeah so can i ask the chief executive to
respond i note your
counselor
i thought i'd intervene only because to
some extent it feels like we're in the
twilight zone in relation to this debate
but
just to help and possibly to avoid
further debate on this topic i already
do um so just to give that reassurance
whenever i'm looking at cancelling a
meeting i will do that in liaison with
all of the group leaders to have that
conversation clearly they may disagree
and ultimately it's my decision as the
monster officer's already highlighted so
by all means you could add it here but
i'm conscious that might prolong the
discussion
just to give you the reassurance that
that is the approach i take
thank you i'm extremely grateful for
having that confirmed thank you
che and chair thank you just just to let
you know that we have now reset the vote
following that discussion so if you
could all place your votes again thank
you
chair just to to clarify your voting to
to adopt the committee schedule as
amended by councillor mellon and for the
second recommendation that chief
executive has the discretion with the
cancellation of meetings
council of mayor do you have a question
i do
i'm slightly concerned that we voted on
an amendment that amendment wasn't
written down anywhere we're now voting
to vote on this including that amendment
i think there is some scope unless it's
written down that that side of house
thinks they're voting on one part of the
amendment we think on a slightly
different amendment you know i would
like to be absolutely clear
what this member is
now it might be that i'm you know slow
and stupid that that's a distinct
possibility but you know i would like
some clarity around exactly what we're
voting on
what is this amendment in detail
okay the monitoring office is going to
help us out here
yeah thank you chair and and um i do
take uh councillor mayor's point uh with
regards to not always having the
amendment written down in the system
when you're voting the amendment that
was proposed by councillor mellon and
was then uh voted on by the council was
to include additional provisional
council meetings in june and in
september so effectively
october i'm sorry sorry
i've turned my page over so i haven't
got it right in front of me
additional meetings in june and october
um so the uh amended motion that you are
now voting on as a substantive motion is
that the draft committee timetable for
22
be approved with the addition of
provisional council meetings in june and
october uh 2.2
is is as uh published in the papers
thank you
thank you very much
uh hopefully everyone is now clear about
that
okay
so i think the voting is open yes please
cast your votes
councillor can i take your vote please
councillor richardson are you have you
voted
do i need to vote again
um
i voted for it twice already all right
he's saying that you haven't voted so he
could just put it through
chair the voting is as 27 4 and one
against thank you
council that's carried so we move on to
the next item please which is uh council
appointments
apparently there are no accounts
no appointments so
at this point in time members i'd like
to take an adjournment
for
where are we 10 minutes well 12 minutes
until 19 30 hours thank you
all right welcome back counselors we're
now going to get back into business with
uh item number 15 on the agenda
these are motions on notice
so we have two motions so with the first
one at 15a
um this is a motion from councillor
mentor so i would like to ask councillor
mansell to move her motion
uh thank you very much chair um
um as it's now um over five years since
we moved to the cabinet model
i think that uh it is now time for us to
review that model um and that system of
governance that we are using
um
to make sure that we are offering uh the
best service to our communities
uh much has changed in the last five
years both nationally and locally
um baber are already conducting their
own review of the governance model of
their council
and as we have the shared uh workforce i
think it is in the interests of our
staff that we also review our governance
system alongside baber
i'm not suggesting uh in any shape way
or form that one system is better than
another
but i do think it is important to take
some time to consider all the options
that are available to us in terms of our
governance model to ensure that we can
continue to offer the best service so i
would urge you all to support this
motion thank you
thank you councillor um could i have a
secondary please
counselor matheson
yes thank you chair yes i i'd like to
second this motion which i think is very
self-explanatory and i'll reserve my
right to have any further say till later
thank you councillor we will now move to
the debate
councillors will be allowed to speak for
once for three minutes and this will be
timed
and uh
we will get cracking who would like to
start
counselor possible thank you very much
chairman um
always interested you hear discussions
on a topic like this governance that
word that we all love to hear
the only thing i would like to say is
though what is the problem here we're
trying to fix every nobody would
disagree of course um with your point of
view sir about serving communities
that's what we're all here to do
irrespective of what political color we
stand on
um but i'm not entirely convinced of the
need for doing this because i don't
actually know um if we have a review
what is the problem that we're trying to
fix that people have come up with i
don't know how it work what would the
cost be can we fit it in etc and i'm not
saying never ever look at this but after
any five years i do wonder if it's a
little premature partly because of
course the last two years because of
lockdown has been
very odd to say the least and i do think
personally um leaving this for a year or
two as we get back to normality might be
a good idea and um i do think at the
moment we are still a sovereign council
we're not baby yes we share officers i
certainly years ago was in favor of
putting the two together but um that
didn't work many years ago although
there was a majority overall of voters
there wasn't majority of sufficient size
um
in in baber for example so i'm not
entirely clear that i can um understand
what's going on here and i'm not sure i
would actually well i'm sure i don't
think i'll be supporting it um at this
stage thank you
council australia
thank you chair uh i'll be brief again
uh uh i wasn't necessarily going to
speak on this other this is purely just
to check that we have actually got the
best system
we're not saying in this motion please
go and make sure we do this or give a
steer to do that it's saying let's have
a look it's actually been way more than
five years since we've had the cabinet
system actually
we converted a lot longer than five
years ago
i don't know how many years we've
actually been in this building
so and we converted many years before
that
and we've been running a uh
option
for authority
up until then so we have had differing
models and it was just a way of
if others are already and our staff
already going through a review process
then surely that is a really ideal time
just to check that we have got the most
appropriate system for the council that
we have to serve our residents thank you
i don't actually accept the premise that
we need to consider
we need to
proceed
just because baber is doing something we
are a sovereign council we make our own
decisions in our own way
and there is no relevance to what baber
is up to
personally
i think
and also although baba are
considering this
there is they have considered it
and it is coming back to cabinet but
that that's not coming back until march
so
to proceed on this on the basis of what
labour is doing
is a totally flawed argument
as i say there's no reason for us to
proceed in parallel with baber
we can do exactly what we want
personally i think it would be far
better to wait and
do it as part of a review of the new
council in the new term
in a year's time
we're all far too focused on
doing the best for our residents and our
communities
and i'd rather not spend the time
uh looking at this
it's not timely
and it's not relevant
counselor geek
thank you chair i would like to um agree
with councillor passmore that we are
indeed a sovereign council um but we
also like to do things efficiently
officers are working on this kind of
thing there's conversation in the
building research is being done and
being consulted ideas are being had why
not capitalize on that why not do things
in an efficient and swift manner i also
completely agree with councillor morley
that we need to be in a position to get
this done with the start with the start
of the new uh council which will be
after 2023 therefore we need to start
getting going relatively soon and i i
although things can move efficiently
here they don't often move that fast and
so i think now is the time to be doing
this to make sure that we do it uh in
time and for the least possible effort
when the leader said about
a better time would be with the new
council
well i think that's the worst time
i think
you need if there's often there's a 30
percent
changeover of of membership
when there is a when there is a an
election
and the wrong time to do it would be
with 30 of the members
new to the council the best time to do
it is in the final year of
of the council
where you've got
experienced counsellors who can
contribute to the debate thank you
council scoff
thank you chair i mean i i i can't see
how we could object to actually just
looking into something particularly as
something's already going on
with our officers at the moment i i
understand i'm a member of the
constitution
review working group i've been very
pleased to be back on this council for
two and a half years we've never even
had a meeting
now whilst i accept that some working
groups are there
in case of or a need of a meeting should
an issue come
about
i think bearing in mind that there's no
recommendation as to what type of model
and the constitutional review working
group could do their work come back to
council and and say well we see no need
to change they could come back and say
well we would think that you would
change to
model a model b or whatever i can't
really see what the objection is to
actually reviewing something and and
looking at something all of these things
that we come here to council for
whether it be budgets housing revenue
accounts policies plans we're constantly
reviewing those things quite often on a
cycle of three years
if we haven't looked at the constitution
and whether it's fit for purpose uh for
some considerable time and i don't know
quite how long time it is i can't see
what's the problem in actually getting
the constitutional review working party
together and actually having a look at
it we may conclude that there's no
change to be made we may not
if no one else wishes to speak then i
could ask council if you would like to
eat i think um
sorry councilwoman
i i i think it did council matheson want
to come back um and then yes i would
like to come back but i'm not sure what
what's political for which order yeah is
it councilman
yes
yes all i wanted to just just to go back
over the couple of of um criticisms
and concerns there have been um
councillor passenger asks is asking is
the problem to be fixed well no we're
not saying there's a problem to be fixed
we're saying there's a question to be
asked that's all
and um and then also yes we agree we're
a sovereign council we could go our own
way but in practical terms it would be
far better to work
with baber members
to have a review
and then to come to
hopefully the same conclusion
and then to bring that back to you
uh for a decision in due course and i i
do entirely endorse councillor welland's
view
that um
doing it over the the coming 12 months
is is actually the best time
um
not the worst time thank you
council man
uh thank you thank you chair i'll try
not to repeat uh because much of what i
was going to say it's very similar to
what councillor matherson um has just uh
has just reiterated um but i i would
like to just may also make the point
that
councillor morley said that she didn't
think now was the time to do it because
we should all be concentrating on doing
the best for our residents and our
communities i'm sorry i thought we were
meant to be doing that all the time so
why not now
and again i would just like to say as i
said for the previous motion actually
where's the harm
in doing a review we're not saying that
there's a problem uh we're saying that
it is it is now time for us to review as
it's been said by other other members we
review a lot of other uh policies um and
procedures that we do why not the
governance model um and and in response
to uh councillor passmore who was
worried about the cost of it
as as i would say if if the staff are
already looking into it with our our
baby members
our fellow members over at baber then i
would think that now is probably the
most efficient time to be doing it
and i certainly agree uh with the
comments that have been made about let's
do it now so that it's there ready in
place for our new council in 2023 uh so
uh again where's the harm in voting for
this all we're saying is we get the
constitution working group to go and
have a look at it uh to look at all the
options there are
and there'll be a recommendation we i
can't we can't predict what that
recommendation will be all we'd say is
let's go and look at it let's look at
our options and then we'll come forward
with a proposal thank you
thank you
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote please
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue please can you cost your vote
councillor willem can i take your vote
please
for the motion thank you
can i take your vote
against
so chair that is a um a draw there's 14
votes four and 14 votes against so can i
ask you if you wish to exercise your
casting vote
i do and that will be against
chair that motion is lost
so that motion is lost
thank you chair
uh
shall i read out the motion and go into
my speech is that or do you want to take
the motion as read or
if you want to save time i can skip it
i think we can go straight to my speech
go straight into your speech
i will do i will do that super thank you
brilliant right first i'd like to start
with a thank you uh
thank you for actually all being in a
room together it feels really good to
actually be here debating with you
people
i'd like to also thank those councillors
and officers who over recent years
on numerous occasions pushed developers
to deliver increased energy efficiencies
on thousands of standard homes we've
been asked to approve each year thank
you for doing that
as energy markets go through convulsions
of change
all those
that benefit from the savings brought
into those increased deficiencies will
be able to continue to flourish because
of these past endeavors
thank you for making this effort every
home you have better insulated is a
family more likely to thrive without the
fear of having to make the choice to eat
or heat
but of course it really shouldn't have
to take so much effort
to deliver the quality of buildings that
we needed and the trade had planned for
over half a decade ago
i will not rake over the coals of the
bonfire regulations but given in
mid-suffolk we have almost doubled our
housing completion targets with some
house builders
still paying bonuses to their chief
executives of over thousand pounds per
house on top of their million pound plus
salary
we have an overheated housing market
with some under insulated homes
current gas prices
are over 115 pounds per megawatt hour
new nuclear in suffolk is guaranteed by
our government at 92 pounds per megawatt
hour and rising while solar wind are now
less than 30 pounds per megawatt hour
energy storage coming in around 50
pounds per megawatt hour and falling the
future transition of energy is now
crystal clear
but we need to insulate our insulate our
homes not just only against the elements
but also insulate them against our
economics
the best way to achieve this is by
energy conservation the better our
buildings could conserve energy as well
as produce it is our environmental
ethical economic challenge as well as
opportunity i commend this motion to
this council and i'll help for your
support thank you
thank you councillor uh could i have a
second to please
come from melon
uh thank you chair um councillor field
would have been here to second this but
unfortunately he's not able to be here
so i'm happy to second this in his place
and i'd like to reserve my my right to
speak thank you
thank you counselor
so we will now move to debate on this
motion counselors will be allowed to
speak once and for three minutes and
that will be timed
so who would like to kick off
councillor byrne
thank you chairman
and thank you
council springer
as you'll know um
like most of us i suspect uh i also
followed the cop26 summit
and i'm pleased to see that the
aspirations in the government's net
zero strategy
having supported our own council's
climate emergency motion
i support the approach of moving more
quickly and i do feel
the general thrust of your proposal has
merit
but i'm afraid i do have some thoughts
about some of the specifics which i
would like to share with you
the code for sustainable homes was
phased out several years ago
and i recall that it included measures
various measures such as cycle storage
and washing lines that weren't part of
the building regulations
when that standard was phased out
the government described how they wanted
to introduce the relevant measures
within the code
into national minimum standards
thereby negating the need for the code
and to help standardize across the
country and across local authorities
the government has committed to reducing
carbon emissions from homes
which is what the changes to the
building rigs coming in from june this
year are all about
the new building regulations that is
these changes are designed to be in
preparation for further reductions in
emissions
which will be part of the future homes
and buildings standard in 2025.
i think a letter to the minister for
housing should be more specific than
simply referring to a former standard
and requesting that the new 2025
standard
be zero carbon for new homes
your second point is really for our
housing and assets cabinet members
but i understand that their view is that
it is difficult to pin our standards
against something
that isn't fixed
as code 6 or equivalent for example
the aspiration and intention behind the
new design guide
and specification
which is being brought to council
alongside the new hra business plan
later this year
is to promote sustainability
and to deliver well-designed and
well-built homes for our communities
the new design guide seeks to lead the
way in sustainable home setting
in sustainable homes setting a benchmark
for the market
councillor your time is almost up on the
final limit of the motion council
officers regularly seek to push
opportunities to enhance strategy
performance energy performance when
negotiating with developers
this is one planning consideration of
many and one which at present does not
attract increased weight in the npps
the suffolk climate emergency plan
expects all suffolk's lpas to develop
policies that require new homes to be
built in line with the 2025 future home
standard and our planners are actively
looking at the steps we need to take
counseling after
my bottom line is that i can't support
this motion as presented
because all that it purports to cover
and more is already work in progress in
numerous ways work by ourselves and by
other agencies
thank you
thank you councillor
does anyone else wish to speak
councillor fleming
yes thank you um thank you very much and
thank you councillor stringer and
councillor field i know the intention
behind this motion
is
is good one and one which i absolutely
support myself
um however i can't support your motion
um
because for one thing
as counselor burn has said the standard
you refer to is
no longer
an accepted standard it's no longer on
the books the components of this
standard have been adopted into either
building regulations
present or future
or planning
standards
and there's no need to write to the
minister on this score if we are
advocating writing to a minister
we needed a minimum to be specific
about the problem we're trying to solve
and offer some constructive suggestions
as to how to solve it
the motion here doesn't solve a problem
in fact the problem isn't
encapsulated in in your suggestions
and number two i do not advocating
asking cabinet
to
adopt a standard for our homes
that
is has already been fragmented into in
various directions it would be a
logistical nightmare and i have had this
discussion with officers this is simply
not a practical way to deal with um an
alleged problem
and
number three we're already doing this
um there's no need for the motion
um so i'm afraid i i can't support your
stan your proposal
and i feel that it's it's redundant but
well meant well-intentioned and i
believe that um
going forward the climate change action
plan as we look at it will take into
account
the suggestions you've made in your
paper and we are doing all we can to
make homes energy efficient and as
emission efficient as possible
there is another part that you mentioned
in your speech about having
virtually
hermetically sealed homes and i think we
need to think carefully about that too
they aren't very healthy we need a good
blast of air going through our homes
especially with covered around so we
need to be carefully think carefully
about how tightly we um force our homes
to be sealed
thank you
thank you councillor
comfort hardigan
thank you
our new design guy
sorry our new design guide has
sustainability at its heart in both
terms of ensuring that our council homes
are delivered in sustainable locations
whereas the most need but also they're
designed with a fabric-first approach to
reduce the need for energy consumption
our new council housing schemes will use
appropriate renewable energy resources
such as air source heat pump solar and
electric car charging points and promote
reduction in water use and encourage
biodiversity to thrive so while i don't
support the details of councillor
stringer's motion i do support the
sentiment which is to promote
sustainable homes across our districts i
therefore welcome this opportunity to
talk about emerging new council house
design guide and specification which is
due to be considered by this council
along alongside the hra business plan
later this year
thank you
thank you councillor harrigan
uh if no one else
would like the word
council warboys
as well as a relatively new councillor
still i think i've been sitting on
development committees
and notice how the language on those
committees has changed it has changed
because of the
council's declaration of a
climate emergency
the aspiration for net zero
and
it has
encouraged developers to come forward
with schemes that are more and more in
tune with the council's aspirations
um but not all developers
some developers still hang on to
the present building regulations
irrespective of what changes are in the
pipeline
um
what is the benefit of a coat six house
maximum accessible
provision for recycling
improved daylighting sound insulation
and security
building to the lifetime home standard
assessing and minimizing this ecological
impact of the construction of the house
these are quite specific things
and i think the point of this motion is
that it wants to we want to accelerate
the move to these this standard we want
to put the pressure on the minister to
adopt these standards
and
quickly
and i think that was one of the things
which came out of cop 26 that the time
is rapidly running out to make changes
kicking the can down the road is no
longer acceptable
the point of this
motion is to put pressure on to
accelerate
the adoption
of net zero in housing development
it is to show that we are united
in
pushing these things forward as quickly
as possible
and
to
really focus on how they can be
included in our own design standards i
do accept that there is lots of good
work going on there is lots of joined up
thinking going on throughout the council
and it is really
heartwarming to
be given this information in briefings
so i'd ask you to support this motion
please thank you
thank you councillor matheson
yes the council of war boys has
happily um
said much of what i wanted to say other
than the simple point that um
sitting on the planning committee being
unable to prevent
developers from installing gas central
heating
um a matter of months for now before it
becomes effectively obsolete is is
incredibly frustrating and i i would
just ask
that those um criticizing what's been
put forward as not the right words etc
that if we gave them five minutes um a
german could they perhaps come up with a
with a some amendments which would make
it um acceptable to them because we
surely need to put the pressure on the
government because it's the government
that are not
moving fast enough to allow us to do
what we need to do
in the planning committee thank you
thank you councillor
councillor mayor
there we go um
a lot of things that we've heard i i
fully support
but if i was the minister and i got a
letter from our first world chairman
quoting an out-of-date specification
would i give any air time before i put
it in 5 13 no
this is too important
not to get it right
and to ask this side of the chamber to
do legwork on something that is
sorry andrew i don't think it's up to
scratch and i think it'd be far better
to withdraw the motion if it's possible
and come back with one that actually
quotes the standards as of today not
standards that as we've heard of today
just a slight
the word equivalent is in there
if you wish to remove that
and and replace it with zero carbon
more than happy to accept that you've
had this motion tabled for over four
months
councillor passed more very quickly
thank you chairman just a couple of
things i'd like to mention i agree with
them roland warboy's i think language
and planning committee has changed i can
only really speak for committee a but i
do know under matthew's chairmanship a
lot of things have been improved we
can't undo
previous permissions we know that but
huge progress has been made it would be
good if all developers did that but i
can also say other things have happened
we haven't waited for developers i think
i could perhaps claim a little credit
with some support for others it is about
better use of scarce natural resources
amongst other things biodiversity
having small changes made for example to
driveways where they're poorest so we
can serve water and so on and we are
doing a lot across party here to make
improvements already and i do think the
biodiversity i mean we all know about
hedgehogs swift boxes you can now get
swallow cups um house melting cups etc
we even had some what was it tiger
crossings at one of the recent recent
developments which i'd never heard of
before um i'm being a bit bit flippant
there but no we are doing a lot there
exercising all these sorts of things i
think that was it in elsewhere we had a
dispute a rather large fine oak tree
we've saved that that was going to be
butchered absolutely no need for that so
i would like to see things really
wide-ranging much better use of scarce
natural resources and please don't
forget
all of this somehow has to be paid for
and you can look at it paying for the
resources but the long-term cost
i think we can all agree on um any
damage there but better use of scarce
net resource and biodiversity i think
it's really really important thank you
very much
thank you councillor barthmoor
um
before i call countler mellon i'd like
to say a few words i think councilman
stringer's
thrust of his motion is probably not
in dispute from from many members in in
the chamber
however the the
the actual wording and detail of it i
think is
rather misdirected
um
and as someone who is on the board of
the midst of a growth limited company
we as a council are actually
leading
in terms of the what the work we do in
providing sustainable new homes and and
council of field
would have been there when we uh
actually let the keys for the first
release of homes uh back in december and
i think you would agree with me those
were built to a very high standard and
we as a council have also
uh agreed that you know with our own
council stock existing stock that we're
going to work very hard to improve the
energy efficiencies of those houses as
well
so i think there is no doubt
that at all about the commitment of the
council towards more energy efficient
homes more sustainable living and its
witnesses by the arc biodiversity uh uh
the
declaration of a climate emergency so i
think on many different levels this
council is already doing this stuff um
and i don't actually see the point of
this motion so um
i shall not be supporting it
counselor melon
yeah thank you chair um
i'm sorry
sorry chair i did have my arm up i think
it was while you were speaking so you're
probably preoccupied um i just wanted to
make the point that in
in 2007 we built
this council built some exemplar
very low energy
highly environmentally efficient
buildings we built a small
group of buildings in a state in
elmswell
which permission for that was given in
about 2005
2005 that's 17 years ago
we were able then
to build
to do um buildings like that but we seem
not able to do it have been able to do
it since then so it's a shame that um
you know as as councillor stringer has
said this motion you know would have
been heard originally um in november at
the november meeting so um you've all
had it
for since the middle of the beginning of
november in fact and it would have been
great to get together or to have
somebody um to come to council stringer
and say how can we do this improve this
if you're going to put this forward
again what can we be doing that would be
fantastic you know and i think you know
it would have been a great piece of
joint working and so given that we have
been able to build and do highly energy
efficient buildings in the in the past
it's a long long time ago and at the
time also they won a rba award
with first one in this district so it'd
be
great if we could all get together and
repeat that thank you chair
thank you account for uh councillor
milan
councillor prev
yeah um
i think um
colleagues that it would be a real shame
to to vote against any
motion uh that tries to
help us to raise um standards in any of
energy efficiency in homes
i think that we should be using this
opportunity to triangulate
our efforts
to
raise these energy efficiencies
now i know that
the argument's been put forward that
code six is redundant but it
encapsulates encapsulates the
multifaceted
um
sort of topic that it is
it's not just about renewables it's not
just about insulation it's also about
the fabric of the buildings themselves
the materials
and
it's it's also giving us the opportunity
to be creative because the wording says
code 6 or equivalent
and so i think that
a better way around this would would
have been to put an amendment forward
that improves the motion rather than
disregarding it all together
i might also add that whilst i
acknowledge that we're doing excellent
work as a council
through the many different tasks and
finishing groups and working with
partners
in the last few years i've been a
counsellor i haven't always been really
impressed with the developments that
have been
permitted in my ward in terms of the
kind of backwards
um
design of them um they're not exactly
exemplary
um still using lots of concrete
which emits lots of co2
you know we're just trying to push
innovation really aren't we
and go a little bit beyond
what we're being asked to do by the
government which is exactly what we
should do
thank you
councillor geek
thank you chair um
i just wanted to draw councillor's
attention you probably already know this
but data published in the guardian today
from climate emergency uk uh with a
checklist of um
of ideas from um
a checklist of of uh
criteria um for districts councils
unitary authorities etc etc county
councils as well
shows that um
mid-suffolk has a score of 58
for comparison uh the county council
suffolk county council got 54
west suffolk council got 65 now i can
leave you all to to go and look at the
criteria but uh we score highly on
mitigation and adaptation we score
highly on measures to tackle the
biodiversity crisis so that's all those
swift boxes and house martin cups and
and so on but we do worse than average
for measuring and setting emissions
targets that's the thing that we really
need to get better at and this will help
us to get our targets up this will help
us to be seen as the greenest county and
it will help us to catch up with west
suffolk i'm sure nobody wants to be
behind west suffolk thank
you
councillor carter
uh thank you and i am heartened to hear
that we all agree that we are trying to
we want to move in the right direction
we want to be improving we want to be
the greenest county
um
but i have sat in
many a meeting a planning meeting i'm
sure we all have where we've been told
we haven't we cannot we haven't got a
planning reason to go against
um but or to advise to improve upon
because it's
government legislation
we've all sat through meetings where
officers have said
we can't we haven't got a reason to
suggest this we haven't got a reason to
um to go further
well this is just we could work together
in suggesting
trying to push for
before
go forwards quicker together
we've all had this for
four months where we could easily
work together as a council
not just
separate sides but say this is direction
we're moving in wonderful we can do this
faster we can do this quicker and we can
actually
write and actually show
our residents that this is what's
something that we care deeply enough to
actually push government for
we are
not just sitting behind lines of drawn
somewhere else where sand we want to
change those lines we want to be at the
forefront and i can't see any downside
in working together as a council and
just
saying to people
saying to government we need to do
better
if anything it makes us look stronger if
we work together so thank you
right if no one else we should speak
i'll call on
uh counselor melon
thank you chair
um uh clearly i'm not councillor field
and um i don't have
either his experience or or his
eloquence but i will just say a few
things in support of this motion um
and i think this broad agreement uh in
this in this chamber
about where we need to go with this
subject
we can all agree that there's a need to
raise build standards
and not least because of the recent
massive rises in energy costs
we we know that a well-built
well-insulated home is going to cost
residents much much less to heat
and and and we do see some very good
work going on in the planning committees
pressing developers uh to to to reach
the highest standards um that we can
make them do
um
it doesn't seem to me that this motion
unduly binds the council's hands it it
is really a kind of steer
in terms of um
pushing
further in this direction um
and i we did bring this motion forward
for the november meeting uh which was
just after the cop meeting and perhaps
would have hit the spot a bit better
then and i obviously realized that the
government has since then announced it's
going to roll out some higher building
standards of building regulations in i
think it's june this year
and we will welcome those we welcome
those things
um
just a couple of words on code six and
co-six um
became advisory it didn't go away it
became advisory
but it's still there and it's well known
and it's understood in in the
sustainable building industry
as a kind of gold standard that we
should be trying to achieve and other
other places talk about passive house
and that sort of thing but i think the
code 6 or its equivalent
is a very good standard to be aiming for
we do want to be providing 21st century
homes
um the standards we have at the moment
a bit like our housing delivery numbers
they are not a ceiling we can go further
and we can go faster
on the first point of the motion um the
chairman of the council will write to
the minister i saw the chairman's last
letter he writes a good letter i have to
say uh and i'm sorry that he didn't
receive a response from that um but i i
think uh expressing our views in that
way it's just one of the the handles we
have to one of the levers we can pull on
um to try and get movement quicker
um
the second point is is not for us to
decide it's it's the cabinet we know the
cabinet has the power to make those
decisions and we and what we're simply
asking is for the cabinets to consider
that doesn't particularly to me seem
very onerous
and then the third one is the council
officers and as people have said the
council officers are asking
um but to me
that third point would give those
officers an encouragement which i think
would be very worthwhile so i do commend
this motion thank you chad
thank you councillor councillor stringer
do you wish to add anything oh yes i do
too
uh thank you and thank you for all the
contributions today i have to say a
little disappointed that over the months
nobody's sought to amend this
because it is well meant and the reason
for choosing code 6 equivalent is
because that's what the trade
understands that's what the layperson
understands within this sustainability
language
but that could have been amended could
be even amended after i speak now but i
fear it won't
the biggest issue is
in between us originally tabling this
motion
this council has approved over 400 new
dwellings
in between today
and
the legislation coming out in june which
will be the earliest no doubt it will
probably slip
as many of these do
we've got timetabled over 650 homes to
be approved by this council in the next
four weeks
so we'll still so those 650 homes will
be at the whim of the bog standard
regulations we have at the moment and up
to the individual endeavors of the
individual councillors on those
committees coming up against current
government policy
that is what that
motion seeks to do
to give those councillors
the
confidence that they have a council
behind them in trying to get to those
standards
and it instructs that cabinet to
consider that consider it and to
actually say to our officers you've got
the free hand to go and negotiate it's
about that period of time between today
and the legislation coming out for those
651 houses i will be voting for this
motion thank you chair
thank you i will now ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office to
conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue if councillors would like to
cast their vote thank you
councillor welum can i take your vote
please
thank you
councillor geek are you having problems
voting
lovely thank you
and councillor otton are you
oh she's left okay right i didn't
realize that okay
yeah
chair that and the votes are 13 for the
motion and 14 against so the motion is
lost so that motion is lost
chair just before the closed meeting can
i just remind cancers that when they go
out of the car park tonight it is going
to be closed the shutters will be down
but can you make sure you drive